[Musique]
breath of the wild a clairement été un
tournant pour la saga zelda et trois ans
après sa sortie
je trouve que encore maintenant il reste
le meilleur jeu sorti par nintendo sur
la switch
c'est alors que deux ans après la sortie
du jeu lors d'un nintendo direct qu'une
suite sera annoncé une suite directe a
breath of the wild et dont nous sommes
toujours en attente
mais c'est là que l'intelligence de
nintendo va faire surface avec ce hyrule
warriors
reprenant le concept d' hack'n'slash
sortie sur un précédent jeu sorti sur
wii ou puis ressorti sur switch l'ère du
fléau possède un but précis maintenir la
hype de breath of the wild
en attendant la sortie de breath of the
wild 2 néanmoins malgré cette très bonne
idée et contre toute attente hyrule
warriors l'ère du fléau n'est pas canon
il n'est pas un soldat officiel et là
c'est la douche froide
pourtant il existe bon nombre d'éléments
intrigant entourant ce jeu donc bref il
y a énormément de choses à dire
c'est un réel bonheur que de reparler de
l'une de mes saga préférée
il est temps de parler de breath of the
wild avec ce hyrule warriors
[Musique]
il faut tout d'abord parler de la
position de nintendo par rapport à ce
projet pour mieux le comprendre le
concept hyrule warriors est un projet
fait en partenariat avec cauet tecmo une
firme qui a enfanté bon nombre d'acteurs
slash l'idée est de faire fusionner la
saga the legend of zelda avec le concept
de combattre et décimer des armées et
donc forcément zéro prise de tête foule
fan service
on veut juste voir les personnages de
zelda déglingué des monstres et ça
marche
le jeu sera très bien accueilli bon
nombre de dlc apparaîtront et le jeu
ressortira dans une version deluxe sur
switch c'est là la particularité
nintendo veut juste proposer un jeu où
le gameplay prime totalement sur le
scénario et où le thème sert un peu de
fan service
tu joues à est relou ayers pour te
défouler
c'est le concept de base c'est très
important à prendre en compte pour
comprendre pourquoi l'opus n'est
possiblement pas cannes et pour
surenchérir là dessus
aonuma n'est même pas vraiment dans le
projet cauet tecmo aidé à l'origine de
tous quasiment et ont juste été mis en
lien avec les équipes de développement
de breath of the white pour garder la
cohérence de l'univers dans le jeu
garder la cohérence de breath of the
wild pour développer et renoir york vers
du fléau
c'est là le hic bien qu'en jeu heroes
loire years soit avant tout un jeu fun
pour son gameplay mis au premier plan et
proche de la caricature d'un véritable
jeu zelda et bien l'air du fléau possède
un scénario complet sérieux et très
relier a breath of the wild trop
d'efforts ont été mis là dedans pour un
simple jeu dax lâche
[Musique]
dans breath of the world nous jouerons
link après un long sommeil de cent ans
le fléau ganon a gagné et pris le
contrôle des gardiens et des créatures
divines tuant au passage les quatre
champions de chaque peuple ainsi que
link lui-même avant d'être placé dans le
sanctuaire de la renaissance
alors que dans hyrule warriors l'ère du
fléau un petit gardien suite à l'éveil
des pouvoirs de zelda se réveillera et
voyagera dans le temps pour prévenir
zelda et ses amis de l'arrivée du fléau
et les aidera à retourner la situation
grâce à ses pouvoirs notamment sur les
créatures divines
nous sommes face au scénario contraire
amenant une victoire et une fin heureuse
à l'histoire
sauf que évidemment que l'histoire ne
peut pas être canonique hyrule warriors
l'ère du fléau n'est pas za préquelle
car les éléments de l'histoire sont
différents de ceux de l'histoire
originelle de breath of the wild
nous sommes sur un concept de what if
cela me rappelle personnellement
énormément final fantasy 15 sur vous ce
pôle est le jeunot racontera son
histoire principale avec de nombreux
éléments qui resteront sans réponse ou
dans le flou et par le biais de dlc ou
encore un roman sorti récemment
nous aurons accès à des histoires
alternatives des histoires qui ne
peuvent être officiel
car la véritable histoire s'est déjà
déroulée mais qui permettent de mettre
en lumière d'autres éléments qui aurait
pu arriver si un choix ou une action
avait été différent et donc compléter
l'univers avec des branches non
canonique mais qui doivent être prises
en compte pour revenir sur l'air du
fléau nous sommes face à l'autre
histoire des prodiges une histoire qui
sera modifié
le biais de l'arrivée du petit gardien
qui redonnera l'espoir à zelda link est
un pas grâce à son pouvoir pour aller
sauver les champions champions qui
seront également sauvé par les prodiges
du futur de la réalité de breath of the
wild et grâce au retour des créatures
divines link et zelda ne sont pas seuls
face à l'armée de gardiens qui finira
par un normalement avoir raison de link
etc etc
un véritable effet papillon donc voilà
irles warriors l'ère du fluo ne peut pas
être un précaire car il ne raconte pas
la véritable histoire du passé de bresse
au foie mais il reste très important
pour son côté d'histoire alternative
néanmoins nous sommes face à un nouveau
problème et ce sera à nintendo de
trancher avec cette histoire alternative
le jeu créer une nouvelle branche à
l'univers de zelda brasseur the wild et
on connaît la pensée de nintendo à ce
sujet la timeline pour nintendo à
l'heure actuelle c'est un petit peu
derrière eux ils ont envie d'innover et
produire de nouvelles choses notamment
avec ce zelda breath of the wall qui n'a
jamais été placé dans la timeline
en trois ans d'existence enfin bref je
n'ai pas envie de rentrer dans ce débat
je vous en ai déjà parlé plusieurs fois
je pense sincèrement qu'il faut attendre
breath of the wild 2 pour avoir la
réponse ultime
sauf que voilà est-ce que nintendo a
vraiment envie de recommencer une
timeline qui en plus répète un petit peu
ocarina of time avec une branche ou
hyrule à gagner et une branche ou hyrule
a perdu eh bien je ne pense pas vraiment
en tout cas à hounoux marc reste dans le
flou comme quoi si un jour ils veulent
développer cet aspect hyrule warriors à
tout servi sur un plateau d'argent
maintenant que nous avons parlé de
l'importance du jeu pour breath of the
wild tout ce côté alternatif qui
respecte à 100% l'univers de breath of
the wild
il faut parler des éléments du jeu et de
ses nouveautés qu'il apporte dans la
saga
je n'affirme pas que nous reverrons
forcément ces éléments au personnage
mais il me plaît à penser qu'ils ne
sortent pas de nulle part
surtout aussi tecmo koei c'est lié à
l'équipe de développement pour être
précis sur l'univers de breath of the
wild
il faut parler
astor qui pour moi est le personnage le
plus intrigant de l'opus bien évidemment
je pense qu'il s'inspire tout d'abord de
sia l'antagoniste du premier relais
warriors
on y retrouve tout ce délire de sorciers
et sorcières de londres qui sont les
antagonistes de la première partie du
jeu avant que ganon ganondorf arrive on
retrouve aussi l'aspect gira m dans le
fonds où notre cher astor souhaite
absolument le retour du fléau et agit en
son intérêt pendant son absence
avant de se faire absorber par son
maître entre guillemets fun fact
d'ailleurs c'est un détail que je trouve
vraiment trop précis pour n'être qu'une
simple création faite comme ça pour le
jeu le fléau est totalement différent
que dans breath of the wild
ce qui est intéressant est que dans
breath of the wild guns est des gardiens
des créatures divines et donc la
technologie chèque pour revenir et se
rebâtir c'est pourquoi il a cette forme
robotique au bras darren d'oreilles
warriors
il a cette forme humanoïde grâce à
l'absorption d'astor et cette
représentation du fléau se rapproche
énormément d'une projection de la forme
humaine de gaines et je trouve ça
totalement ouf car on en avait parlé
dans le trois théories sur breath of the
wild 2 comme quoi le fléau ganon est une
projection de lettres sommeillant sous
le château qui cherchent à se réveiller
c'est comme si heroes loi riorges avait
aussi pris en compte
le trailer de breath of the well 2 c'est
d'une précision assez surprenante
et pour en revenir à astor il me
conforte de ouf dans une des théories
que je vous avais proposé dans breath of
the wild le roi d'hyrule nous affirme
qu'il ya 100 ans 1/2 vin est venu
prédire que le retour du fléau et est
imminent
et que la solution pour le détruire
était cachée dans les terres du royaume
les créatures divines ont été
découvertes ainsi que les gardiens des
champions ont été choisis pour les
contrôler et cetera et cetera
sauf que gagnent le fléau a gagné grâce
à sa prise de contrôle sur les gardiens
et les créatures divines et c'est ce que
je vous affirmait à l'époque
pourquoi avoir enterré les gardiens et
les créatures divines
si ce sont des anges ainsi formidable
pourquoi toute cette technologie fut
cachée et bats la preuve avec le retour
de ganon donc et si le devin avait tendu
un piège au royaume d'hyrule pour
justement faire revenir le fléau grâce
au gardien et aux créatures divines et
6e de vin était donc à store on sait
très peu de choses sur ce personnage
mais en vrai tout concorde à store est
une sorte de prophète qui souhaite
maintenir le destin ou zelda et link
perdent face au fléau
et si dans breath of the wild astor
était également présent mais agissez
dans l'ombre pour faire revenir le fléau
et si il était à l'origine du clan guiga
est celui qui a dirigé une partie
d'échecs à à se tourner vers la
résurrection du fléau
tout reste possible
alors évidemment ce ne sont que mes
analyses mon avis personnel voir mes
fantasmes
mais tout cet aspect d'histoire
alternative est vraiment très
intéressant et je tenais à vous en
parler en tant que bon fan de zelda
j'ai vraiment passé un excellent moment
sur ce hyrule warriors et ça m'a
vraiment relancé dans la hype breath of
the wild que j'avoue je commençais un
petit peu à oublier j'espère que ma
vidéo vous aura plu maintenant il suffit
d'attendre les décisions de nintendo et
surtout aonuma concernant une
potentielle suite pour cette branche
comme un i roll warriors 2 qui sait
peut-être que quand breath of the wild 2
sera sorti un second rôles warriors fera
son apparition reprenant les éléments de
ce breath of the wild 2 pour nous
proposer du coup une autre histoire
bref n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleus à vous abonner à la chaîne
évidemment et puis surtout me dire vos
idées et vos avis concernant ce rôles
warriors l'ère du fléau je suis vraiment
très curieux allez c'était argot rock et
que le lionheart soit avec vous
[Musique]